I don't envy you hosting this uh block
this is the craziest thing here's why
because none of it makes any sense I
don't think anybody agrees with this and
Jesse I'm going to challenge you I think
he's the only person or he she is the
only person that can't be blackmailed he
posted all the worst pictures you could
possibly have yeah yeah oh you can't
blackmail him he's already did he
blackmailed himself but you got him uh
there's no way they check this guy out
if they did check it out and they should
pursue this you just say listen and all
this stuff is posted and you go you're
the guy who should handle nuclear waste
you'll be perfect you're only 35 with
not much of an energy background and
tend to spend a lot of time in different
outfits so good job by the way stealings
I've never even heard of that waste I
mean this guy takes suitcases he's gonna
be looking at 10 years in jail so he
gets the job of a lifetime and he he
rewards himself and the people that put
him there uh by stealing luggage and
getting arrested and embarrassing
everyone I I don't think I think 99 of
the people watching us uh who have a
television think this is crazy town and
objectivity and individualism is not
white supremacy can I make this one more
point before you go to Justice because
he is a political appointee so he's not
protected by the career Civil Service
rules uh you serve at the pleasure of
the president you could be fired for
saying hello the wrong way to the
president and you can be out so the fact
that they didn't fire him immediately
even after he was arrested is a issue
yeah and so I guess the question Jessica
is if it is all about wokeness
overconfidence it puts America in a
tough situation and if senators are
writing to uh the department of energy
and asking for answers on how they vet
their employees and they're not getting
answers after a third letter I mean can
the administration just hide and say
we're not going to tell you this is an
important position oh I totally agree on
that front and I thought that Senator
barrasso who's kind of been leaving
leading the charge on the Republican
side has done a really good job in
asking questions about this hasn't
mentioned once that this is a gender
fluid person or talked about pronouns is
is it about National Security and that's
where this conversation should be and
that's where it should stay in terms of
just making wokeness appointments I I
would push back you know heartily
against the idea that Kamala Harris and
this person are comparable in any way in
terms of getting their position and I
know how you feel about her but that
woman is qualified for this job and
everybody who wins an election runs
production is picked for a position has
certain attributes and yes it does
matter that she is a black woman the
same way that it mattered that Mike
Pence was a white Evangelical When
Donald Trump picked him up because he
couldn't have won that voting block and
I don't know that's it I don't think
those color of the skin got Mike Pence
the job you think no his religion
because Donald Trump you know 50 time
philanderer after the you know what tape
needed some help with people of Faith
right who who weren't interested in
voting for someone like that so I just
want to stop diminishing Kamala Harris
in terms of no but you could say she's
great I'm not going to stop the woman
who can't say anything confident without
laughing I had so Bill Maher and Barack
Obama have been talking about this
making people feel bad about when they
don't know what to say right about
pronouns or just don't make people feel
bad about things that also on the up
flip side of that it doesn't take that
much to find out how somebody wants to
be addressed and if you do know that do
not intentionally make fun of them or
challenge the way that they live for
your own comfortability no one should be
made to feel bad about it like you said
I'm nervous to say XYZ you know he I am
nervous because that's criticized I said
no one should be made to feel bad if
they're making a genuine effort to treat
people with respect and dignity okay how
about this I identify as a doctor
refer to me as Dr Waters fine PhD or
medical I'm PhD are you going medical oh
I'm gonna do that I'm an operator
he's going to let you do anything